I started thinking about it when people have said like,
you know,
you pick,
could you beat,
uh,
like 12,
12 year olds?
I fuck up 12,
12 year olds.
Okay,
sure.
Maybe a hundred percent.
What if they're organized?
I don't know.
They don't have a chance.
They don't have a chance if they all come at you at once.
Nope.
And they don't care about getting beat up.
First of all,
everybody cares about getting beat up.
You're talking about non humans now.
Well wait,
what if you start training them at a young age?
I'm going to fuck him up.
I don't have a chance.
The first one's going to get kicked into a person who's going to get kicked hard
for sure in a panic and then I'm just going to start smashing,
so,
okay.
Okay.
I listen.
If I had a fight,
me and 10 other dudes in a fight,
a 500 pound man,
that's more coyotes.
Shit.
I know.
It's a weird looking ones.
It's all very,
yeah,
he buries,
need a lot of berries.
Yeah.
Um,
if I had to,
uh,
get 10 friends and we had a fight,
a 500 pound hulking man,
we'd be fucked to be fucked.
We'd be fucked.
We didn't,
wouldn't have a chance.
What about 12?
Like Duncan trussell's.
Could you take that a little bit bigger now it's current form performance.
Absolutely.
All up.
Wouldn't have a chance.
They are grown by the beard.
One of them in front of me at some point.
The problem with Dunkin as you wouldn't be able to really do any damage if he
got close,
he could punch a square in the jaw and you'd laugh it off like vehicle Rocco's.
Yeah.
You'd be like,
okay,
but if you got to deal with like three Burt crushers,
right,
I'm probably going to get fucked up.
Even if he's not a trained fighter.
The first guy you have to take out immediately hard as hard as you can.
You also have to show consequences for everybody else.
We smoke way too much pot for this pod.
I believe it was the right amount.